激励他往另外一个方向走呀。
我们说人物弧线呀。
我在这里再给大家说一下这个人物弧线啊，电视剧的人物弧线。我们说电视剧的人物弧线真正要比电影的人物弧线是要完整的。
电影有时候没有弧线的，或者弧线没那么大。我前面说过啊，我说教材里面说电影呃一切人物都有人物弧线，我是不同意的，有些没有。
开始什么样，最后还什么样，从人物的。
角度来讲，但是电视剧你可以充分的去做人种弧线的。
充分利用人物弧线是个球形这个原理。
就一个球景啊。
假设啊。
呃本来是个胆小。
对吧在这个点上嘛。
胆小的一个主角嘛，然后经过一段时间的成长，走到对面变成无比的勇敢。
对吧。
但是呢勇敢不就勇敢隔壁不就是狂妄吗？勇敢了你不就狂了吗？
对吧然后狂不就又出事了吗？又走到另外一端，变得无比的。
叫谦谦虚。
你明白这个意思吗？
就是电视剧中的人物的成长是可以反复成长的。就说这个360度的弧线，我我们说那个那个电影里面有一些主角是会走到180度的对面，但是电视剧是360度转的。
你可以。
经常成长。
啥意思呢？就是你这二十级你我说的难听点啊，你要他妈给我撑满。
你一头一尾的点过来好。
开始很穷，后来想贩毒，那最后就是个大毒贩嘛，成为大毒枭，对不对？
绝面毒师吗？
开始很穷。
得了癌症了，很落魄，像翻身。
这个这个怀着一肚子对社会的不满。
50岁生日这一天，查出自己有癌症。
那么最后就是成为大促枭。
那在这个过程中。
你是不是要给我把它填满呢？
假设你写20集，你是不是要给我给我把它填满？那么阻力来是不是可以多来几次？
是不是可以多来几次，然后选择是不是也可以多来几次？
是有好几次机会可以走别的路的，给他几次选择。
就是你得给我把它撑满呀，你这个序列是可重复的。然后人物弧线呢是可以。
走到对面，再走到另外一面，再走对面，懂这意思吗？胆小变勇敢，勇敢带来了狂妄，狂妄在被变谦虚。
这么去去扩充的。然后。
等到你这这条这个表填满。
填的细致了以后，你就像切蛋糕一样，比如说把第二集切出来拿出来一看哦，第二集要做成这些事情呃，要完成这些任务，要完成这个这个A这个角色的呃，他的激励，完成B这个角色，他的灵魂黑夜，完成C这个角色，他的呃遇到第一次阻力。
遇到啊这个。
呃，第一这个角色的一次过激行为，然后你再去用事件。
用两件事儿，我们说假设是双线叙事或者三件叙事，用两三件事情把你所有要办的这些事情都给它盖住。
不难，假设你设6个主要角色，那你三件三件事情盖66件6个任务ge得住的。
没有很难。
所以这也就是为什么电视剧都是多线叙事，明白这个意思吗？电视剧都是多线叙事，就是因为他人物多。
他服你不可能说一件事情，ABCDE全部都交进来撞撞车咣一撞，唉大家都在这儿啊，那肯定不行嘛，所以还得是两三件事情把这些。
切蛋糕这一个竖条全任务全给它办掉，这就是我说的。你写电视剧的时候，你一定要记住你是在编，你是在编织，懂吗？你在编织一个东西，编织的核心是什么呢？整体编织。
按人物边。
单级编织按事件编。
然后不要忘记。
你的。
人物关系是有自己单独的一条。
未知的你不单独把它写出来，你会忘的。
相信我，这是我的经验之谈，没有人教你这个这是我经验。
你这样切出来以后，你就会发现哎，第二集需要AB甜蜜。
他俩刚开始合作呀，第二集非常甜蜜。所以你这第二集里面A和BA和B相遇的时候非常甜蜜。
非常甜蜜。
往上走，感紧往上走。
明白这个道理了吗？这就是简单的思路，基本的思路并不简单啊，基本的思路。你掌握了这些，你电视剧你就不慌了，你设计起来，你心里就不慌了。
既然讲了这个。
这个基本思路了，我再给大家多说几点。
注意事项吧。
就比如说在总体序列里面，你经常会发现这个假设这个A是大主啊，他有时候顶不到头。
20级或者有时候30级吧，30级你顶不到头吧。你感觉这这个大男一或者大女一，这也也没那么多事儿。
你这时候应该怎么办呢？
有这几种方法啊。
就是。
记得咱。
说过1种类型片吗？
类型片的大量引进。
内型片始大量引入。
你完全来在这里，比如说你需要。
你需要A在这里。
呃，遭遇一个挫折。
那你这个挫折完全就可以是一个被制度化嘛？
明白这个意思吗？
然后A跟B在这里要遭遇一次大误会，那你可不可以引入一个鬼屋呢？
他俩被困在一块的，引入一个鬼屋，一个大的事件群。
明白这个意思吗？就是你可以把类型化的故事填装在。
一个电视剧里。
前好几个类型。
一部电视剧里可以装下好几个类型。
的电影故事。
可以放往里抬。
这个是完全可以帮你扩充篇幅的。还有就是我说的序列是可以循环的。
我们说那个电影故事里面讲时序列嘛。
1个序列嘛。
你在这里序列是可以循环用的。
都可以倒回去再用了。
就根据你你只要一头一尾。
能走到目标，但是你可以前进。
三步后退两步，再前进三步，再后退两步，明白这个意思吧？序列可循环，可往复，这也是一种方法。
还有一种方法就是我说的人物弧线可以。
利用这个球形体。
不要这。
光想着到对面去了，对面的对面还有对面，它是个球形，还有就是主题反复呀。
主题反复呀，我们说我们说电视剧也是有要素的啊，人物事件主题也有主题要素的。假设你看他这个。
呃，贩毒。
正价值和负价值守法还还是违法。
可以反复。
可以让他反复正义和邪恶反复。
我们说电影里面开始邪恶占上风，后面最后正义占上风。在电视剧里面，你可以此起彼伏。
就主题也让他多反复几轮。
明白吗？就是说在电视剧里面，这些都是可以往反复的，不用担心。
猪肚子嘛，电视剧是肚子要大。
但是一头一尾。
就要打死了掐死的那说到这个一头一尾，我再给大家说一下，电视剧的第一集往往是最难写的。
王往是很难写的，为啥呢？你会发现第一集全部他妈用来介绍人物了，啥事儿没想明白。因为你光介绍人物又很枯燥，观众又不爱看，但是你不介绍那你这这你你。
你还得介绍，对吧？你篇幅还不够。
所以电视剧往往有第一局的一个困境问题。
在这里啊有几个解解决方法，呃，电视剧的第一集讲究叫短而有利嘛。
必须短而有力，就是说你不要长，不要反反复复的交代人物的呃欲望状态呀，然后那个他的呃起始动作呀，他的前史呀，他的。
各种纠葛和选择呀，不用去介绍的那么全。
第一集要短短促而有力，快速的进入剧情。
一定要注意这个第一集不要写成所有的人物登场幻灯片。
明白吗？这个是想到这里啊，我给大家提一下。
就是嗯。
具体有什么方法呢？啊？比如说分开出场。
比如说你AB主角群的话，你可以让C跟D在第二集出场。
或者是呃扔一个在第二集第三级分开出场，这是一种方法。二呢是反转。
就说你A和B在第一集出场，你也交代不过来。那你比如说先你先着重交代A，你把B。
在第一级里面做成A的。
对手或者A的一个反派假反派。
你先让他先以坏人。
形象登场，那这样的话，你就可以简单交代，造成一个误会，先让他先出来。
然后第二集再把这个误会解开哦，原来当时不是这个样子，原来A也是主角啊，哎也挺好的，就是说做一个反转也可以，就是说你自己去想办法啊，多去看片子，多去看嗯其他作品，你会会会会会知道会有很多方法的。第一集我在这里讲一下，就是怕大家犯这个错误。
就是觉得哦原来第一集有这么多任务呀，哦我切这个蛋糕，切出第一集的时候，发现哇A的登场B的登场C的登场D的登场A的身份，B的身份，C的身世，D的童年天哪，然后你第一集全给我干这个了，你第一集就会很难看，就不要这么做。
一定要避免这个问题，新手很容易犯这个错误。
对第一集一定要短促而有利。所以你可以想想办法，比如说分开登场或者是反展登场让比。
本来是主角，在第1集里面以反派。
形式登场就可以了。，有很多方法的，好吧。
这就是我说的。
整体上以人物去构建。
单即以事件去构件。
明白了吧？
但是我说啊。
我说这。
其实还是经典虚实。
叫传统叙事。你这个ABE呀或者ABC呀，它虽然是个主角群。
看起来是好几个人。
本质上他是。
有共同目标的。
明白吗？就观众是能理解他们有共同目标的，所以跟着他们走了。
你给他们做撕裂，做感情上的纠葛，分开分分合合。
只是增加这个戏的呃趣味性和篇幅，对吧？但本质上AB你是还是有他有一个共同的目标，在在在拉着观众。
拉着这个观众这个小车观影着这个小车往前走的。我们说这叫经典叙事。
那有没有非经典叙事呢？
这几年真的很少了啊，这几年很少了，我说为什么很少了？就是因为。
市场不一样。
竞争变激烈了，你已经不能像以前那样叙事了。
我说句难听话啊，就是如果红楼梦现在拍。
假设他不是名著啊。
他没有名著给他撑腰。
他是竞争不过经典虚事的巨的。
因为你在天天在那看，你不知道他们要干嘛，你知道吗？
林黛玉，你想干嘛？贾宝玉，你想干嘛？
对吧除了王熙凤儿有点事以外，他想管好这个家，然后但是老有人给他捣乱，这个家不好管，其他人想干嘛？
你没有主动力。
你不是经典叙事，你如果不是名名著，这一口仙气顶着你。
这种戏是不适应现在这个时代的。
但是有没有呢？也有。
也有还有比较明显像大宅门。
前美也是这样的剧，他就是非经典叙事大时代。
也是凡正带大的哈，你看都是这种剧，为啥呢？因为他他想要讲的人物很多，他要涵盖的内容很多，所以他不会是一个简单的，而且它是历史跨度又长。
他不会是一个简单的。
谁想干一个什么事儿？那那种戏怎么写？
那种戏啊其实就是。
当中换一换主角，然后主角换。
他等于多个电视剧。
就是你一部电视剧是多个电影拼出来的，多个电影事件群拼出来的。
那种非经典叙事的电视剧呢是多个电视剧品种。
你说白锦琦的每个时代。
他相当于就换主角了，少年白景琦，中年白景旗、老年白景旗、青年白景旗不是同样的人了。虽然青年中年都是呃那个陈宝国演。
但是他的人物设定。
他的目标。
他的欲望都已经变了。
他相当于换主角了。
所以说那种剧呢。
你也得。
找到他贯穿始中的那股那股劲儿是哪？如果不是人物的话，它是什么？
他是什么贯穿始终？
我是不提倡大家去写那种剧的。
至少从业前十年。
别去写。
那种戏第一。
非常冒险。
你想写好很难。第二。
没有明星就免谈了。
这么说吧。
那种戏真的是靠明星撑下来的，我不是跟你说吗？他靠一股仙气儿撑着你一直看。虽然你一直换事件，换主角，换换欲望。
换目标，他为什么一直撑着你看？
咱们说的实在点。
明星。
当然过去那种戏多，为什么？因为过去我呃电视剧是广告的马仔的那个时代，那种剧是主流的，明白这个意思吗？为啥呢？因为他要填大量的时间，所以他要大量的角色，大量的目标，大量的事儿。
在那陪着你矫情，一直在那啊让你有东西看。因为你看那种剧的时候，你也没有很花力气去看肥皂剧嘛。
所以你没有较真儿，但是这两年那种剧为什么那么少了呢？从国际上来看，就是因为你是主动观看了，你主动观看的话，你不会去看一个红楼梦的。
因为他没有事儿。
他没有大鸡儿。
所以我还是推荐大家写经典叙事。
当然可以写多主角，就是你把主角群。
经典叙事的目标事件目标立在那儿，然后把主角拆成主角群，然后反派也可以。就是说你写的时候，你知道这是个反派，但是观众看的时候认为他是个主角，你明白我意思吧？就是这个C啊，他可以戏份很多很出彩，他有自己的目标，他只不过他这个事儿不是。
不是主力然后他这个事呢给给主角群的事儿会会会。
会成为障碍，所以他就是叫反派，但他不一定是坏人呀，反派不代表是坏人嘛。
明白吗？
就说你可以做的很丰富，但是不要去去跳出经典叙事的这个框，不要去搞那个。
大时代大宅门这种这种。
宏大的这种格局。
没有明星。
而且现也不太适应这个时代，我再说的大逆不道一点吧。
大宅门是我非常尊敬，非常喜欢的电视剧。我先把这个放这儿。
他。
高山养脂非常牛逼。
但是我说的大遇不到的话。
大姐们如果没有明星称。
可能也不行。
没有明星的。
号召力没有明星精湛的演技。
他也下不来。
那是什么卡斯啊？那个这个电视剧的卡斯。
质量啊。
你去看一看那是什么卡斯啊。
对吧没有比这更豪华的阵容了。
就是这个问题。
好吧。
所以我推荐大家写电视剧的时候，也遵循经典叙事。
然后利用。
利用编织的思路整体给我编人物，单级给我编时间。
记住人物关系单拉一条。
否则你会忘。
这不是这不是什么规矩，只是我告诉你，你不拉出来，你会忘的。
会忘了他们的人物关系要起。
主角主角群要撕裂。
要分分合合此起彼伏。
好吧，记着这些。
在这里既然都说了这么多了，要不再多说几句。
电视剧还有没有除了这种叙事，我们说经典叙事，还有那个那个那个那个叫啥？
那个那个那个那个像大姐们那种宏大的叙事。那个你知道他是怎么玩的，它是多个电视剧组合。
但是我不建议你现在去碰。
那还有什么别的方式吗？
也有。
也有我比较熟悉的。
就是。
所谓的。
所谓的单言句。
单元句和情景句。
也是一种。
单人制。
严格来说啊，情景剧也属于一种单元句。
就是我们就说单元句吧，单元句啥意思呢？就是一集一个故事。
就是这个一集这个这个故事啊。
它比较完整，这一集的故事是有序列的。
是有发展呃是有这个这个呃相当于一集算一个小电影吧，你可以这么去理解，它有起程转折。
单极有启层转壳，独立事件。
然后那他为什么也就要连续剧的一种呢？他人物连续啊，像情景剧长景也连续呀，对吧？所以他也算电视连续剧。
但是单元句情景句。
去用独特的门类。
这种剧是怎么写呢？
你就把它按照单级。
电影时间来写。
短促的提成转合。
明白这个意思吗？
他的人物。
是固定的。
人物是固定的，像单元句，一般是什么？探案。
或者是什么急诊的故事的故事，编辑部的故事，每一集来一个新的事儿，每一集来一个新的事儿，你去处理。
一数理情景剧，其实也属于单元句，就是这个道理。
就是这个道理。
这是一种。
他其实是确实是。
就是电视剧还是广告的小弟的时候。
产生的一种。
产物，但是现在还是你如果能写出强剧情。
也还是可以存活的。
那我们就来我就简单说一下这种戏怎么写吧啊。
就他还是有它存在的道理的。
他有它存在的道理的。
就说单元句。
单元句情节类的单元句啊。
情节类的单元剧它有什么特点啊？它强势件。
长世件，比如说探案，他每集一个大案子。
每一集都扑朔迷离呀。
长世界。
因为他不需要顾及。
明白我这个意思吧？他不需要顾忌，哎呀，我这局要考虑B的出场，哎呀，我这一局要考虑C要倒霉，或者我这一局考虑D呢，要灵魂升华，不要去考虑这些事情，单集给我一个强势件，每一集给我一个强势件，所以他的事件就会很强。
等级强势件呢。
就一直玩这个。
这是他的优点，他的看点。
然后情景剧呢。
强人无关系。
就强人无关系。
啥意思呢？情景剧喜剧居多啊。
就是你看这个跟他是冤家，他呢就制死他，他见到他怕的要命。
对吧他呢什么事儿都隔路，给所有人捣乱。
就他有一个很强烈的人物设定和人物关系。
让你看内个。所以情景句跟。
那个那个跟综艺其实挺像。
这两种。
剧的优点。
都是可以无限复制，可以无限复制。
这是他的优点。
缺点是啥呢？
就是粘度低。
就你看了上级，看不看下级都可以，不会牵挂他都那么回事，年度低。
因为这两种剧啊我写的也挺多的。呃，所以我单列出来给大家讲讲，就说如果你们碰到写这种剧的时候，呃，呃它的难点和这它的关键点已经说了啊，就是单元句你要有强世界。情景句呢你要有强人物关系，你就可以实现无限的复制。
一直拍一直，然后它的缺点就是年度差多。
那如何弥补这个缺点呢？
如何弥补这个缺点？我们说你看啊单元就它一级一个事儿，你是不可能有这个的，你是不可能有这个弧线的，明白我这个意思吧？
情景剧就更美了。
那你如何弥补你这种剧它没有黏度，就是粘度的问题。
就以我的经验啊，我给我给大家说一下，你就买了一条暗暗线。
这是我的一般做法，就你给这种句加一个暗的主线。
暗的主线比较好用的就是爱情，这是肯定的。有两个人若即若离，若即若离，永远在擦枪走火。
这就是一条暗的主线。
他俩不会在一起，因为在一起之后，这个人物关系动了，你就这个。
呃，这个你就这个失去复制的。
复制粘贴的这个这个这个这个作用了。你如果要人物关系发展，那你写连续剧不就完了吗？
但是呢你一直。
让观众逗观众痒了痒，对吧？这是一种，或者是呢某一个角色有秘密。
还有个什么事儿，一直怕被大家知道，也可以埋在那里。
对吧。
或者是。
嗯嗯。
某一个角色一直有一个什么。
祝愿。
一直没有解决。比如说他来到这个城市，其实一直是想找到自己的亲生父亲是谁。
那么格几级你就骚。
脑观众一下，哎呀，好像那个好像是格几级脑观众一下，这就是一些小技巧增强。就是在这种戏当中，因为它的先天弱点就是年度。
我用我的经验，因为这种戏我写很多，我用我的经验告诉大家一声，你可以在哪些方向，哪些地方弥补下下点手，搞点小技巧。
增强一下来的黏度好吧，因为这种戏的它的先天粘度比较差，但是它有优点啊，他长寿啊。
拍个3G4G5G是吧？为什么现在这种。
G播剧很多呢，就因为它有这种优势，它可以。
他可以放量，它可以。但是。
其实啊那个。
沈查那里是不让拍。
不让拍续集，所以能拍续集的剧。
他们都会点啥。
虽然他们也改名啊。
不叫乡村爱情。3、乡村爱情4、乡村爱情小夜曲乡村爱情圆舞曲。
改名。
但是大家都知道你是虚吉，你又神过了，就说明你。
本家老师，你可以会点啥。
所以现在这种剧是不多了啊。
我单提出来讲一讲，是因为很多人会问我。
他们打听我这种剧应该怎么写，我给我给大家分享。
那这节课咱们就是讲了电视剧。
他的创作方式。
其实是创作思路，因为很多人在写电视剧的时候，他没有思路，谁都知道电视剧的写法。
啊，也是从电影那儿来的，也是那些人物事件主题呗。
但是呢他没有思路，我就告诉大家，这是个思路。
好吗？然后我们说那电视剧有连续剧，又有单元剧，它各有自己的优点和缺点。我们说单元剧缺点很明确，就是它年度。
但是单极强啊，单极我可以给你看一个很糊乱的东西。
那所以。
反过来说，连续距离的时候，你也要注意这个问题，你的黏度是很够的。
就是每一集都吊着观众，哎呀哎呀哎呀，也不知道下下面是什么回事，他死没死，下一集接着看，就你年度你是先天不缺的，但你先天缺啥？你容易缺单集看点。
这就是我说的，你容易某一集里面全他妈在铺垫，你知道吗？你你这个呃这个所有的人物走到这一集的时候，全都在铺垫。
你要解你要当心这个问题。
就保证每一集有单机看点。
单元句是不缺单题看点的，它缺年度连续句呢是不缺年度的，但是你容易丢掉单机看点。
因为你在完成任务，你每一级都要完成很多任务，你容易事件不精彩，这个是你要特别注意的这两种句可以对比着自己去琢磨琢磨。
那咱这节课就说不少了，先说到这儿，有什么不懂的，咱回头再补。
下课啊。